on today's show we talked to a woman
whose son was in a terrible accident
and the whole family's wrestling with
what to do next
talk to a woman who's been married for
20 years and she's struggling with adult
sex life
we talked to a guy who found out his mom
has been panhandling
and he doesn't know what to do next for
sure
this is an earmuffs show for the little
ones and seriously
don't have your kids in the show
probably ever stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is delony
with the dr john deloni's show
take your calls about your life
[Music]
everything that's going on these days
your mental health your relational iq
education concerns parenting loss love
laughter all of it anything and
everything that's going on in your heart
and mind give us a shout
man we are walking alongside you you can
watch the show on youtube
at youtube john dolone you can listen to
it here on this podcast
i think that's only two places you can
get it you can imagine it in your mind
and uh a couple there's a couple things
here we got to do first 844
693 3291 that's one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one
listen hey switch to the overhead camera
real quick james was making fun of me
said i look like a lumberjack today
and i want everyone to see that he's got
blue plaid on
like he's some kind of fisherman hey
blue is sophisticated red is just like
i just got done cutting down just just
drinking the haterade dude
i think my uh if anybody owns a chainsaw
company wants to invest in this show i'm
your
podcast guy this is going to be mental
health and chainsaw advice
effective immediately and trees and
maybe you could cook us some flapjacks
i don't even know what that means i
don't even know
what cooking flapjacks means but hey
give me a call 1-844-693-3291
for your mental health tree needs
your lumberjacking and flapjack cooking
this is the worst podcast on on all
platforms
listen it's terrible but keep us going
or go to johndeloney.com
show um you can fill out the form and
check it out hey
today i want to dedicate this this show
to two important people
one um is first to my good friend
general thompson his mom josette
maurice thompson passed away last week a
remarkable woman whose mission
in life get this was to adopt the
unadoptable
if the world said hate we don't want
them
man josette and her husband said i'm in
she adopted over the course of her adult
life she adopted 16 kids she fostered 30
to 40 more
her mission was to love love love some
more
she's tell stories about the sounds of
nazi boots pounding through her
childhood home she grew up in france
she's she's seen a lot and because of
her love
and her husband's love gets gets get how
love works
because of her and her husband's love
and commitment to the least of these
my good friend and mentor john noel and
his twin brother were adopted
he found a home saw what love
looked like met his wife
tanya and years later they became a
mentor to me as a dad as a professional
as a husband
they were who i called when my wife went
into labor the first time
because of because of jose
maurice thompson so was john noel and
tanya and because of john will antonia
so is john doloni
and sheila and hank and josephine the
ripple effect of love goes
on and on and on
this beautiful story we mourn her
passing she lived an extraordinary life
i'd also like to shout out my great aunt
joy who also passed away this past week
at the age of 93. she was born between
the great war
saw the great depression the dust bowl
world war ii cold war my family
she was an extraordinary brilliant
talented woman
of fun wisecracking all of my smart
aleckness that's not true half of it
comes from from her she was the spirit
of my mom's side of the family
here's the thing both of these
trailblazing women
they won life they lived to an old age
they navigated the craziness in this
world
they slid into home with no tread left
on the tires which is exactly the way we
should
all hope to go so thank you to these two
extraordinary women
one i'd never even met and one i knew
intimately well
thank you so much for for who you were
and what you've been to all of us
so all right let's go straight to the
phones today let's uh we're gonna turn
the show around
we're gonna go from flapjacks to
actually helping other people let's go
to connie in
houston texas connie what's going on my
hometown how are you
i'm doing well with dr john thank you
for taking my call
um my 21 yeah my 21 year old son
had a terrible car accident last fall
and basically it crushed his left arm
he is floundering he does not know
what he's going to do for a vocation
his hobbies his identity his
his everything is um based on two arms
and um we're still in the mix of
of surgeries i mean he just had surgery
this morning actually
uh another one so um
i don't know how to help him so what was
he doing
as a profession um just
finished school to be a mechanic oh man
and that's all he ever wanted to do
has he lost all function in this hand
and this arm
um essentially they're doing just a
what do they call it salvage where he
won't be able to move his elbow all the
way and he's still waiting for his
nerves
his wrist doesn't work properly yet
that's a whole nother
surgery set of surgeries coming up um
they saved his arm but it doesn't look
the same
he lifted weights for three hours a day
before this
um you know he's it's never going to be
the same it's
never going to work the same and he just
i mean that was his everything so i just
i worry about him
and trying to figure out how to help him
so let's start with you um you said the
word never several times
this has affected you too in a
really an existential way walk me
through how you've been feeling the last
few months
don't make me cry dr john yeah you
called me dude you called me
yesterday walking me through it how are
you
i'm fine until i start talking about it
i miss my son and this is presents
he's a big guy and he's lost 35 pounds
he's he's not he may see anybody's thin
and he's tall and he was all muscle
before
and he doesn't walk straight anymore he
he you know he just he used to laugh a
lot more he doesn't he laughs once in a
while but he doesn't laugh as much as he
used to
he just um he just isn't the same person
so it makes me sad yeah are you the same
person
no absolutely not i'm not the same
person but it's not
yeah i am where'd you go
who are you now
i have to put my fixer hat back on i am
a fixer
i've been through a lot of crap with
over the years with
my husband died seven years ago which
did not help this son
i've had breast cancer i've um
i'm a widow yeah like i said before um
i am a fixer i will get through this it
doesn't all
it doesn't ultimately affect my life
my job is to fix him up and send him
back this happened out of state
and he's back with me now and we get
along fine that's
not an issue but um
i'm trying to help him he doesn't even
know what he doesn't know yet
right or what he does know yet i mean
we're still
you know to a 21 year old this what
three and a half months is a drop in the
bucket for his life
but to him it's his whole life right now
it's he just wants his life back
right
how uh how honest do you want me to be
with you
i can i can be real honest with you or i
and
i can or i can give you some some tips
be honest with me i i make him mad
sometimes because i'm an optimist and i
say things that
he's like mom you don't know that you
don't know if it's going to be better
and i said but you don't know that it is
going to be as horrible as they say it's
going to be like they don't know because
they don't see this walk in the door
every day this is a very weird
surgeons are brilliant but it's up to
him for a lot of this too
about how much he gets back and doesn't
get back and
luck you know it's just all of that but
so he can do whatever he wants to do
i think you are a
you desperately desperately want to be
an optimist
and i think you say the right things and
you
can you can become that as a as you can
reach into your tools bag of fix it for
everyone around me
and one of the tools is light in the
room and you know how to
turn that tool on but i think this has
rocked you from the inside out
and i think you are as scared and
nervous
and heartbroken about his future
probably more so than he is
you are right he's 21 he's a teenager
basically
right um
and here's the thing
you can't fix him right right i can't
fix him
you can't and there's no worse feeling
for a parent in the whole world than to
watch someone that you love hurt and
you've done this before
and you couldn't fix that one either
right
right and some people respond to that
that level of powerlessness by
letting go of everything and others say
that will never
happen again and they clamp down even
tighter and tighter
and then a second thing like this can
rattle somebody to their core
right
was were you involved in this wreck in
any way
no did you raise a good young man
as a single mom yes oh yes does he love
his wife
he's single oh he's single okay i
thought he said he had a wife okay
no um is he somebody that you're proud
of
yes like not just like um pretend but
are you proud of the man he's turning
into yes
i am okay then i want you to know that
you did
your best and that you did good
the most gracious thing you could give
him right now
is a couple of honest truthful responses
you can let him know hey i'm heartbroken
for you as your mom
and i'm not going to tell you
everything's going to be okay it's going
to be
but it's going to be different some of
the words you used when you first called
was
he's never going to be the same he's
never going to get it back he doesn't
look the same
and that this is all going to be this
way
and man he just wants to get his life
back he wants to get this back we just
want to get i want him to get his body
back
and here's the thing it's not going to
come back it's going to be different
right and it can be a different kind of
good
and it can be a different kind of
awesome and a different kind of could
never have imagined it
but it's not going to be that right and
so
the more he feels a disconnect between
the words coming out of your mouth and
the mom he knows and can feel
the more he's gonna have to put on his
fix-it face so that he doesn't hurt you
and you're gonna get into this weird
dance of making sure the other person's
always okay
and nobody's ever telling each other the
truth that
hey this really sucks and this is scary
and this is not the rest of your life
but kind of is the rest of your life you
know all that that pattern right
and so
i hate this for you as it comes to him
you nailed it man you know exactly he's
lost multiple
identities right the identity of that
sucks for men is that you're only worth
what you can achieve and you can only
work
like you're only worth what you
accomplish through your
big muscles and he's a weightlifter and
he's a mechanic
and he's an able-bodied person and
and-and right so
that part for the time being is is
squashed
beneath those things are
the more important virtuous traits
somebody who gets back up somebody who
gets back in the ring
somebody who does the grinding grueling
every day of rehab
even without knowing if this is going to
work or not someone who endures yet
another surgery somebody who is still
kind and respectful
and begins to say okay cool life dealt
me two two twos
and a three not a great hand so i'm
gonna have to figure another way to play
and that's gonna come if you really lean
in to encourage him to grief
a massive grief process don't compare
and put him on a timeline don't force
him to be joyful and optimistic but put
boundaries on him
that say yeah you're allowed to be sad
and your butt's at my house so
i'm gonna expect you to get up and take
the trash out you can carry that with
one arm
that's a giant arm right and you're
um your butt's gonna make breakfast too
right okay um
i don't know if this is a appropriate
place for this it is what it is we're
already into it so my best friend on
planet earth
was um my oldest friend
that i've ever met that i've ever known
since we were zero
um after college was in a life-altering
car wreck
and i'll never forget um he has very
little use of all his arms and legs
anymore he's still
still close we still keep in contact on
a regular basis
and he's one of the most heroic
extraordinary people i've ever
met and his little brother and another
neighborhood friend of ours are still
friends to this day
and i'll never forget the conversation
that the three of us had around pancakes
while he was still in the hospital
and we said what are what do we do now
and we decided we're going to continue
to treat him
like somebody that we love which means
we're going to still pick on him we're
still going to give him a hard time
we're still going to have high
expectations for him
we're still going to love him and if
he's got to go to the bathroom we're
going to help out
and we're going to invite him to the
concerts and we're going to
help him with his wheelchair too does
that make sense it became
everything it became all of it all at
the same time
and it just became a new different life
and i know he wouldn't trade anything to
go back to be able to run
and be free and play pickup basketball i
don't make any
like illusions about that but i do know
that
all of his heart his family's hearts all
of our hearts have
grown because we said we're still gonna
have high expectations for you we're
still gonna treat people with dignity
with kindness
with love we are gonna continue to
default to you we're gonna continue to
support you
right so when i tell you that you've
been through you've been through
heavy heavy loss before tell me how that
how is it going to be different this
time
well before it was i was a
just mental but it was just mental
we went through some stuff let me tell
you he's my youngest
and we went through a lot of stuff and i
think some of that's still there for him
that's part i think that's part of the
issue too
this is physical though this this is
mental and physical
it's spiritual it's who am i right it's
who i am
yes yes who am i if i'm not muscles and
i'm not a mechanic and i'm not the big
strong guy my mom needs who am i
and for you if yet another person i love
got hurt
god oh my who am i right
and you are a resilient strong
smart loving mom who is
i think ready to go one step below where
you've been
which is pretending which is trying to
prop him up which is saying hey
it's all gonna be okay you're gonna keep
working hard and you're gonna keep
maybe not maybe not
maybe you're not going to be a mechanic
anymore you're still going to be person
to character you're still going to be my
boy you're still gonna be worth being
loved
and we're gonna figure out what's next
right i'm still gonna have boundaries
you're not gonna be ugly in my house
right you're not gonna be ugly at my
house
but we're gonna laugh i'm gonna give you
a hard time
and my oldest friend on planet earth
he still can't run he's still
wheelchair-bound he will be for the rest
of his life
but i still love him he still
accomplished a lot and encouraged
a lot a lot of people he still brings me
joy and makes me laugh it makes me
frustrated makes me angry when he sends
me stupid political stuff
he still makes me cry
and i named my kid after him
i named my son after him and so his
legacy will continue on and continue on
and continue on and i tell you that to
tell you this
what your son needs is all of you
not pretend you not almost you
not the one that wants to fix but knows
deep down you can't
he wants you he needs you and then on
the hard days he's gonna really need you
on the easy days he's gonna need you
he's gonna need to learn boundaries he's
gonna need to
dig deep and find himself he's probably
gonna need a professional counselor you
know that
you might benefit from one as well
but this won't define him if people
around him tell him the truth if people
give him space to grieve whatever that
looks like and doesn't compress and put
weird time limits on it like you should
be picking it up by now but also holds
him accountable
says you do gotta go to work you're
gonna learn a new skill
and he is blessed to have you as a mom
he's blessed blessed to have you as a
mom connie
i want you to keep us surprised of how
he's getting better
i want you to let us know how things are
going and as he continues to
grow i'd love to have him call the show
i'd love this
to have a chat with him he sounds like
an awesome guy
thank you so much for calling and um
yeah
thank you so much man this is a hard
hard season i know um all right let's go
to let's take another call let's go to
elena in
portland elena what is going on elena hi
dr d how are you couldn't be better how
are you
pretty good so what's going on
well um i have
been married to my husband for a little
over 20 years now
and we have
been experiencing over the course of our
time together
um a lot really
problems with intimacy in our
relationship
um both emotional and physical
intimacy and i'm wondering how i can
get him to see
a sex therapist with us okay
so tell me be a little more specific
walk me through some of the
the challenges um
i i don't know what
our hey hold up elena hold on
yes we're super into this already so
it's all good
you're like i can hear like so and
we're all in you just go for it okay hey
listen there's like seriously 16 people
that listen to this podcast
at the most right four of them are my
brother he just has
like four different monitors opened
anyway it's either 16 or a million or so
either way
it's all good so we're we're in it go
for it
so it's just i don't find our sex life
very fulfilling
okay what does that mean so that look
like he's not good in bed
he's not adventurous you ask him for
things and he says i'm not doing that
like what do you mean i feel like he
shuts me down
when i tell him what i need from him and
it creates a cycle where i avoid yep
which creates
another situation where he angry at me
for avoiding and you're getting a weird
that weird
sucky uh marriage dance right so yeah
and i want to break the cycle i love him
dearly i want
for us to be happy yeah and
i i need i need to break this cycle
somehow
and i i'm at a loss for what to do well
i love
love love your spirit like you're making
my heart feel good that you're
invested in this this is so awesome
um so when you say you tell them what
you need
what do you need i
tell him how i want him to touch me i
tell him what i need
him to say to me um i felt like a
kindred to a caller
in several shows back well
she asked her has
been she felt like she was talking a
different love language than her husband
then that her husband was kind of
shutting her down and i'm like oh oh
that's me
yeah yeah so why does he
why does he shut you down well it
i know that he comes from a
rather traumatic upbringing okay
um he his the nature of his job
is he's exposed to great amounts of
trauma
uh on a regular basis what's that job
he's in law enforcement okay um
and so he
he didn't have the best example of what
a loving relationship looks like
okay uh growing up and
i think that part of that spilled over
into
he didn't really explore his own
sexuality
okay does he believe that
you love him and cherish him and value
him
yes i think so you know sir you think so
no i i'm i know so i tell him regularly
okay so not in the ways that you think
like um and i'm just speaking broad
generalizations here i'm totally
gendering this
nobody write mean things on the internet
but um
like sometimes the trap is i wash his
clothes i make his dinner
i fill in the blank he knows how much i
love him
and that's not always the answer to that
question
and so posed another way
has he ever communicated to to you
here's how i would really feel valued
and loved
and you said sweet i'm all in
he hasn't communicated that to me okay
either verbally or like uh well even
not so do you love and cherish yourself
i try to okay
so you said you want to be happy
walk me through a picture of what happy
is
that's one of those amorphous words that
ends up the finish line moves on us when
we chase it right
until we finally know what it is
um
for me that would be that we both
feel secure enough in the relationship
that we're not concerned that
the other's going to leave because of
these problems
so do you think he's going to leave
i have expressed to him that i am
powerful that he would
okay are you going to leave
i don't want to that's
an expertly avoidant answer are you
going to leave
i'm not giving up without a fight okay
that's awesome
i just don't want to be the only one
fighting that's fair
that's fair so when's tell me about the
last time you sat down
and not in a fight or not in a
frustrated moment but sat down and said
i want our life to have reckless
reckless rambunctious wild sex
i want to be able to be so
enmeshed and in love with you in such a
wild way here 20 years into this thing
that we are tangled up and that i'm
having to hide my phone because of the
things
that you send me that i've asked you to
and vice versa and
and and but i need some new tools and i
want you to come with me
have you ever had that conversation with
him
not that explicitly no
okay so here's here's the way forward
especially for somebody who's
experienced
um trauma sexual trauma who has a
high traumatic job
and i've been in that same situation
when somebody comes at me especially
with something as sensitive as sex
especially something as sensitive as
my body something as sensitive as
me right for people who have experienced
trauma or
work and living trauma are experts at
walls
real quick right he's really good at
that yeah of course
and even better at mirrored walls
so the things you throw at us we can
throw up a wall real quick and it
bounces right back and you end up taking
the brunt of your own complaint right
you feel bad about saying something or
trying to get help with something et
cetera right
and then you feel more lonely and more
lonely to which then i feel lonely
right and then i blame you for my
loneliness and we just get in this weird
circle
so the the way through that
is for you to say really explicitly
we are two decades in and you are the
man that i married you're the man that i
love you're the man that i
want to take this our sexual life our
sexual intimacy our sex life don't even
use words like intimacy use words like a
like a someone who is
just ravenously desiring this guy
and say i am ready to go to a level that
both of us don't even
know yet and i speaking about you i
don't have the tools to get us there
i would love for you to explore this
with me because i'm ready to go
and if he says now i'm good man i'm
gonna watch the game
then that's all the answer that you need
right
and if he looks at you like i don't know
another person i don't know one off top
of my head that wouldn't look at their
wife and say
okay i'm a super all in and you can tell
them
i'm scared about how this is going to
work this is gonna be awkward for us and
i'm nervous about it and i'm
super super all in but i wanna go get
some tools
and if he's in law enforcement like
every cop i've ever met in my life and
i've known a bunch bunch of them he's
gonna say i'm not going to some
therapist whatever
then you can say i'm going to and i
would love it if you came
and at the end of the day that's the
best best you can do and you can really
double down on
healing your heart learning some new
tools and then letting him
see the benefit of these new tools
you're learning
and my gut tells me he'll follow right
along with you
i know a lot of brave law enforcement
folks who get over that initial hurdle
about counseling through that initial
hurdle
about therapy and then all of a sudden
their entire
world is different because they learn a
whole new language
on how to be scared how to say i don't
know how to
put their guard down take off that
bulletproof vest and the vest underneath
that vest right which is the one that
protects their soul
and say all right if we're going to do
this let's go all in
right does that sound exciting or no
exciting and scary yes tell me about
scary
um
the scary is you know what if he just
says no yes and that's me and that
that's my
that's on me no no no no elena that's on
every
human in the world
every single person listening to this or
watching this just went yes
because every relationship whether it's
two weeks or 20 years is a risk
and every time you say hey there's one
more thing
i learned more about my wife we've been
together for over 20 years
dating and married i learned a lot about
her this year and she learned a lot
about me that i didn't know
and she didn't know whoa right
and so it's a risk it's a super risk and
it's scary
but what's the alternative
it's just to sit there and continue to
let the air slowly drain out of this
thing
you see where it's headed you know where
it's headed
he knows where it's headed so at some
point somebody has to turn and face this
fire
and say i'm gonna be the one and you
said it here
right here to me you said i'm not going
down without a fight
and the beautiful thing here is the
fight is more awesome sex
that's the fight i'm i'm all in somebody
walking through the lobby just looked in
and was like whoa what are y'all talking
about
this more awesome set right
about being fully known about finally
being loved in a way that you go
yes and that he goes whoa what have i
been missing
right you don't sound like you're all in
on that i
i am i am
hey listen i don't know what you do for
a living do not be an actress because
you are not selling this
why did this suddenly get scary no
it's you've known him for two decades
why does he get scary all of a sudden
i don't know it it's not scary in that
it's it's just
i'm i'm hoping he's going to go along
for the ride
okay so let me tell you this you ready
don't hope
you've got to go if you go into this
conversation with one foot already out
just in case
you can feel it you can feel it you can
know
this man she's she says she loves me but
she's hedging her bets
you've been married for 20 years
either there's something else here that
you're not telling me about
or you gotta just jump and by the way
man if you're in love with somebody for
this long and they're not all the way in
the pool man
everybody in the room knows it your kids
know it your friends know it
and especially that little six inch gap
between the two of you in bed feels like
a hundred miles apart
at some point one of you and it sounds
like you has got to just say enough
i want this to be ravenous and reckless
i want to be so obnoxiously in love with
you that
literally our kids are embarrassed they
are
embarrassed and i'm super okay with that
because my life is not making sure my
kids aren't embarrassed
my life is making sure that i slide in
like i said about those two women's at
the top of the hour here to begin the
show
we slide into the end of our lives with
no tread left on the tires i want no
conversations left had
i want to have fully risked everything
to that person that i said i do to i
risked everything went
all in and yeah elena he could say dude
i'm
i'm sorry i'm out and god that would
suck
but if that's the case he's already out
now right
and then you get a clean cut and you can
go figure out what's next instead of
just slowly the air leaving this thing
but go all in tell them you're going to
learn some new tools tell me you're
going to go figure some things out and
you want them to be along for the ride
because both of you are going to benefit
everyone around you is going to benefit
his work's going to benefit you're going
to ben everything gets better
when a couple is all in on each other
all in
and i'm excited for your heart and your
soul and the fact that you said the
magic words i'm not going down without a
fight
and if all of our fights were about more
better sex god almighty what a great
world that would be all right so i'm
going to
go to quick email real quick um
this email is from bob man this we got a
series of these emails
um and i keep bringing them up here do
the right thing listen to this
i asked my brother if he would be my
power of attorney if something happens
to me
he said he doesn't want that
responsibility come on bob's brother
what should i do
number one get a new brother brothers if
your brother comes to you with that
level of vulnerability and says hey will
you be my best man i mean best man we'd
be my power of attorney
best man's a party planner power of
attorney is somebody who
closes the party down right take that
responsibility there is no higher honor
than somebody comes to you and says i
trust you so much you can do the right
thing the heavy thing when i'm gone
but i know that conversation's hard i
know it's awkward life is full of hard
conversations
life's full of harsh realities we've got
to start facing that
more and more and more our team put
together
the how to talk about your legacy guide
how to plan conversations how to get on
the same page with your spouse
how do peop ask people hey will you care
for my family when i'm dead
because it's gonna happen hey will you
be my kids can my kids come live with
you i trust and love you that much
that's not for everybody but at least
learn how to have that conversation
right
text legacy to 33789
legacy 33789
it's a free guide you lose nothing
and it's worth it
bob i'm sorry your brother said he
doesn't want that responsibility
i get it though it's heavy and it's hard
but man
somebody called me and asked me to be
their power of attorney and i tell you
what it was an honorable moment
it's a moment of honor hmm legacy three
three seven eight nine all right let's
take one more call let's go to peter in
fort lauderdale florida peter what's up
brother how are we doing
hey dr d thank you for what you do hey
man thank you what's going on
um well i've been struggling with some
news i found out a couple years ago
that my mom has actually been
panhandling
um so we've talked about it but it's
still you know
i guess it's still waiting on me a
couple years later
have you talked to your mom about it
yeah um
i mean she's struggled with money her
whole life you know since i could
remember
and a friend of mine um said that she
they saw her you know with a
like a cardboard sign asking for money
you know yeah um
so we did we did talk to her about it
and she admitted to it
um but said that you know she was just
in a hole and uh needed some quick money
to get out of it
um we my her sister my aunt right she's
she has a little bit of of this probably
the best financial situation of the
family
even offered she said okay how much do
you need to get out of this hole
and was willing to you know write a
check right there but my mother refused
and then completely shut down
doesn't want to discuss it anymore you
know
hey can i just tell you man that sucks
i'm sorry
i'm trying to wrap my head around like
me and your situation man that's hard to
see hard to hear huh
yeah i mean i think i'm struggling more
because like
she's she's always been very generous
but now i have my own kids
yeah so she'll wanna she'll want to give
my kids like a christmas present or a
birthday present
yeah and the only thing i'm thinking is
that that money came from her begging
um man there's a couple of things here
number one
uh how old are you man i'm in my 40s
okay how old's your mom
uh 60s so is there any plan
for 65 70 75 is there anything down the
road
um for her i don't think so
security any sort of well i guess that
yes
but i know she's she's worked her whole
life and then
right into her 60s her job was
outsourced so she was kind of like
forced into early retirement yeah
um and hasn't been able to find another
job since then okay
so it's been a couple years and i as far
as i know she's getting
you know social security but i i don't
know of any kind of
you know 401k or any other you know
retirement plans
um so do you have i haven't spoken to
her about that do you have brothers and
sisters
i have a an older brother yeah have you
all sat down and had this conversation
yet
is he is he trustworthy in that way i'm
about it but he's not
he doesn't seem as concerned about it as
i am you know he's
he's about his mom panhandling right
yeah
i understand what would the resp i'm
trying to put my head around i don't
want to throw shade at your brother yo
but like what would you
what would you say to that look all that
sucks dude how's the game like
how do you respond pretty much i mean
no i i said you know we need to get her
help we need to find out what kind of
you know situation
she's in you know i i'm like this can't
be her retirement
plan yeah um so but he
he just says you know well she's going
to do what she's got to do kind of
kind of an attitude you know
well hey here's the sucky part he's
right you know what i mean yeah
um kind of like the last caller i'm not
going down without a fight but
he's right um man
i wish i had more for you here's here's
the
well let me ask you this before i start
rattling off here
um you said this has been bothering you
for a few years walk me through what's
been going on in your heart mind for the
last few years
well yeah i mean you know just just the
image
of my mom you know holding a cardboard
sign right right
um it's very painful so have you have
you gone to get involved have you driven
up and said get in this car
and taking her to get pancakes somewhere
and just be like what is going on man
no what is what has stopped you from
doing that
i don't know that's i guess that's a
good good advice
i mean that's that's square one if i
know my mom's on the side of
a street corner brother i'm gonna tell
you right now again i'm not hating on
you
i'm just telling i'm gonna get in the
car and go get my mom out the street
um have you ever sat her down in a
not in a fight but just in a hey i'm
coming to hang out with your mom and
just said hey what's going on
i mean we tried when we first got that
news uh-huh
and you know and she just i don't want
to talk about this anymore you know
she kind of just shut everything down um
so every every family's different every
mom is different so
um i'm known for having a pretty direct
personality okay
but if i find out that someone i love my
mom
just trying to put myself in your shoes
and she says i don't want to talk about
it
i'm going to say i don't care what you
want to talk about my mom is not going
to be panhandling that's not a solution
to life
so we are going to talk about this would
she say screw you and get up and walk
out or would she
put her head down and be so grateful
that somebody punched through that
wall she's got and then
said what do we do next like what would
her response be
i think based on the last time we spoke
about it she'd walk away
okay here's what i'm not able to do if
i'm you
i'm not able to know that i did every
what's the worst that's gonna happen
she's gonna be right back where she's at
right right and so are you married right
now
yeah okay so here's what i would do if i
was you
um number one i wanna just say dude
i'm glad that you still love your mom
you still care for that tells me that
you've got something in your heart
that's not going to sleep right until
you know your mom's sleeping right and
that means you're a good man
and um so good for you
i do think you've got some action ahead
of you asap okay
um i think you need to get with your
wife and set up whatever boundaries are
going to be boundaries
as if mom said okay would you let her
move in
if mom said okay would you help
supplement rent if mom said okay fill in
the blank
get your boundaries firm and it may be
none of those things like we don't have
the room for her to move in we don't
have
any spare change in our house um that's
not something we can do
cool but get with your wife and set up
some really firm boundaries
and then you gotta get on the horn and
to get your brother and say hey i'm
gonna have an intervention with mom
we heard about it again that she's out
begging on the streets again
and we're not gonna let mom do that and
if he blows you off he blows you off
but you know at least i invited him into
this conversation which you don't want
to have some hardcore conversation
and then him find out a couple months
later and then be like oh you just left
me out of it bro like you know what i
mean make you the bad guy on that deal
so invite him in say hey i'm going on
this day at this time
and we're we're done with this
and then be real direct with your mom
tell that you love her and that this
isn't safe
and you want to come up with some other
solutions whether it's getting her
connected to regional or local
services or whether it is helping her
find a job whether it's giving her a
place to stay whether it's giving her
food money whatever that happens to be
however you can help support her
and then at the end of the day you'll at
least be able to put your head on a
pillow not knowing everything's okay
but knowing i did everything that i
could do and i would also bring your
kids along on this deal too
because i want them to see their dad
going to the ends of the earth for his
mom
okay okay and i want them to
love grandma and to know grandma and
here's another thing
um i'm gonna do this i want you to stay
on the line
kelly is gonna give you a year
subscription to ramsay plus which is
all of the financial tools for my from
the guy my old
my boss here dave ramsey i was gonna say
my old man he's not my dad he kind of is
but not really he signs my paychecks
no my dad's my dad but it's got
everything from the financial
piece university classes in it to the
the apps
all the stuff and this is starting from
square
one and you're gonna be able to
use that with your mom if she's
interested if she's not
then you can use it for your family if
she's interested
this will walk her through step one and
i don't care how old you are
how young you are it's never too late to
say
starting today i'm gonna follow this
plan and you know dave ramsey he's
helped millions and millions of people
get out of debt
this is bigger than that he just teach
people how to handle their money which
means he teaches people how to handle
and live lives with intentionality right
how to be whole
and so this is i'm gonna i'm gonna give
you what i can right put a tool in your
hand
and you may have to call local services
you may have i don't know
whatever that is but i'm not going down
i'm not gonna sleep at night knowing my
mom's doing that without at least
knowing i did everything i could to get
my mom off the street
everything i could i'm gonna bunk my
kids up for a season i'm going to
call my brother i'm going to call her
church i'm going to figure something out
until she says i don't want that man i
don't want to be in any of this stuff i
like i can make good money
doing what i'm doing forget you get out
of my life
and um that'll suck but at least you'll
know
right at least you'll know thank you for
that call brother thank you for your
heart
um get involved and get active and then
call me back email me back let me know
how those conversations go how those
plans go and um
man all right so
as we wrap up today's show let's do this
um i got some songs here i got some
songs here
you know what i didn't even mean to man
but this song is one
because we talked about my good friend
because we talked about the two
extraordinary women who passed away this
past week
i'm gonna wrap this song this show up
with a song from 2007
it's a secret track on bruce
springsteen's magic album
it's called terry song
and he wrote it about a friend who
passed away and here's what he said
well they built the titanic to be one of
a kind but many ships have ruled the
seas
and they built the eiffel tower to stand
alone but they could build another if
they
please the taj mahal the periods of
egypt
are unique i suppose but when they built
you brother they broke the mold
now the world is filled with many
wonders under the passing sun and
sometimes
something comes along and you know for
sure it's the only one
the mona lisa the david the sistine
chapel jesus
mary and joe and when they built you
brother they broke the mold
and they say you can't take it with you
but i think they're wrong
because all i know is i woke up this
morning and something big was gone
gone into that dark ether where you're
still young and hard
and cold just like when they built you
brother
they broke the mold
this has been the dr john dolone show